مع خبر لايلون ماسك فمن جديد يثير ماسك
الجدل ويقسم مستخدمي تويتر هذه المره بحرب
تغريدات هالي ثولف سنه موظف من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه في شركه تويتر تساءل في
تغريده مواجهه لايلون ماسك عما اذا كان قد
طرد من الشركه ام لا بعد تجميد حساباته
لتسعه ايام رد مصر قائلا ما العمل الذي
كنت تقوم به فاجاب الموظف بسلسله تغريدات
شرح فيها وظيفته والانجازات التي حققها
اثناء عمله مع منصه تغريدات لم يمضي وقت
طويل حتى تلقاها لي بعيدا الكترونيا بفصله
فقرر المطالبه بحقوقه لكن ماسك واجه
الموقف برموز الضاحكه وحتى شكك في صحه
اعاقه الموظف وعلل بانه يتحجج ان اعاقته
تمنعه من الكتابه في حين كان يغرد ويرد
على متابعيه السجال الكلامي مع الموظف
المفصول فتح عليه ابواب الجحيم خاض فيها
ماسك حروبا كلاميه مع المستخدمين قبل ان
ينتهي الامر باعتذاره